2eme numéro du 78 sport bonsoir Anthony
26 minutes pour faire un point complet
sur l'actualité sportif du weekend oui
tout à fait aujourd'hui une fois n'est
pas coutume on va parler football au
lendemain du 64e de finale des moins de
19 ans de l' s g Guill en cours face à
la joser mais aussi course et Bike and
Run avec Vincent Guillon le le président
de Versailles triathlon la désormais
traditionnelle compétition par équipe
mélangeant vélo et course à pied dans le
domaine du château de Versailles qui se
déroule ce dimanche et comme d'habitude
en fin d'émission tous les résultats du
weekend et il y a eu beaucoup
d'actualité beaucoup de résultats ce
weekend et on va débuter par du football
svère desfit pour gu en cours c'est ver
des f même si les représentants du club
sont là il nous ils nous font la
gentillesse d'être d'être présent ce
soir autour de la table Olivier Jean res
greégory Chassin et Jordan dousin tous
les trois joueurs capitaine et et coach
entraîneur de de des moins 19 de l'ESG
bonsoir à tous les trois bonsoirons
alors au au lendemain de cette défaite
un 4 à0 on peut pressentir que
l'addition est peut-être salée mais
est-ce que vous êtes déçu en tant
qu'entraîneur justement Olivier de bah
de la performance de vos joueurs non pas
du tout déçu non non non même très fier
d'eux franchement très fier d'eux pour
le parcours qu'ils ont fait et puis et
puis voilà on est tombé sur plus fort
faut faut le dire on est ils étaient
plus forts que nous VO combien de
divisions d'écart 5 C division C
divisions d'écart donc c'est c'est quand
même énorme hein et c'est des c'est des
enfants qui font que ça pratiquement
toute la semaine donc voilà non non non
il y a y a il y a pas de regrs à voir
même si comme vous avez dit le score est
un peu sévère on va dire mais bon sur
l'ensemble du match il y a a voilà il y
avait quand même une grande différence
et puis la joser c'est ce qui se fait
mieux à l'heure actuelle dans la
catégorie puisque ce sont les champions
de France en titre chez les19 les MOS 19
ans ex exactement ils sont champions de
France en titre et en plus ils ont gagné
six fois la comment dire la la coupe des
gambardela et voilà quoi donc c'est
quand même un bon club et pour le club
de gu encour c'était la première fois
que vous atteignez ce niveau 64e de
finale une vraie enfin une première
historique hein dans dans l'histoire du
club en tant que joueur grégoryi et
capitaine ça a été difficile au niveau
moral à encaissé la défaite hier ou pas
bah la défaite encaissé pas pas
tellement dur mais le chiffre dur parce
que 4-0 vous ariez aimé mettre au moins
un but ouais au moins un but un but ça
aurait été bien quoi ça été bien mais
c'était dur c'était vraiment dur on dort
on dort bien le soir de d'un match comme
ça parce que c'était un peu votre rêve
quand on s'est on s'est vu pendant toute
votre préparation c'était un peu le mot
qui ressortait c'est notre rêve c'est
peut-être le match de notre vie on dort
bien la nuit un peu justement après
après un match comme ça après un match
comme ça moi j'ai bien dormi moi j'étais
fatigué vraiment fatigué pas trop déçu
tout de même déçu ouais mais c'est passé
il faut dire que tout va bien anon il
tout va bien c'était il y avait quand
même un sacré enjeu derrière ce match je
vais me tourner vers le gardien puisque
c'est vrai que là sur sur un match comme
çare gardien c'est ça doit être
compliqué mentalement non très très
compliqué il y a eu des faits de jeu qui
nous ont pas souri et voilà donc ce
score un peu sévère à la fin du match
vous pouviez vous pouviez faire quelque
chose ou pas vous vous sentiez
impuissant sur sur sur les
arrêts on peut toujours faire on peut
toujours faire quelque chose disons mais
bon il y a rien à redire penalty si
des faits de jeu comme j'ai dit discuta
mais bon on va pas revenir sur les
décisions de l'arbitre la défaite la
défaite était est évidente mais le score
un peu moins très bien alors avant de de
revenir plus amplement sur cette
expérience cette épopée en coupe
gambardé là je vous propose de regarder
le film de de cette rencontre face à la
jocer nous vous avons suivi toute la
semaine à l'entraînement les derniers
moments dans le vestiaire tout le
service sport de de la chaîne était
mobilisé l'épopée de de l'ESG un sujet
réalisé avec avec Patrick Jacques de
dixmud et Guillaume
camps de finale pourrait être le match
de leur vie depuis le tirage au sort
mi-décembre le choc face à la joser est
dans toutes les têtes joueurs
entraîneurs de l'ES guillancour ont du
mal à rester en place mais pas question
de changer les habitudes à
l'entraînement ce soir-là au programme
atelier de vivacité et conservation de
balle comme tous les mardis on sait
qu'on fait du foncier le mardi avec un
petit peu de jeu de ballon demain soir
on fait un petit match amical et jeudi
comme d'habitude ça sera plus de jeux
ballon avec les gardiens et tout ça mais
on change vraiment pas plus que ça
l'habitude les entraînements quoi oser
n'est autre que le champion de France en
titre de la catégorie tout simplement ce
qui se fait de mieux dans l'Hexagone
mais ce palmarès n'impressionne pas les
jeunes cinquantinois ils feront tout
pour vaincre l'ogre bourguignon et imité
éepinal en Coupe de France tombeur de
l'Olympique Lyonnais il y a quelques
jours ces clubs làà c'est beau pour le
foot on va dire parce que c'est rare que
des clubs comme ça ils arrivent à
s'imposer face à des gros clubs donc
nous on va essayer de faire la même
chose créer la surprise pour moi ouais
ils ont deux jambes et de bras comme
nous VO là on est plus motivé que jamais
là carrément là c'est je pas c'est comme
un rêve pour nous tous on est heureux
mais si on peut aller plus loin on va y
aller on va tout faire pour lors des
qure premiers tours l'entraîneur n'avait
pas anticipé la séance de tir au but un
moment crucial où Jordan dousin gardien
de but de l'ESG sera plus que jamais le
dernier rempart c'est un exercice que
j'aime bien mais si on pouvait pas
arriver ça serait mieux mais s'il y a
les penalties il y aura les penalties on
fera avec il y a des techniques mais bon
souvent c'est l'instinct pour la plupart
les jeunes Guillant courtois jouent
ensemble depuis 5 voire 6 saisons plus
que 11 joueurs c'est une bande de
copains qui voudra à tout prix continuer
l'aventure le staff a transmis des
messages sur le mur du vestiaire à
quelques minutes du coup d'envoi chacun
se prépare à sa manière c'est alors que
le gardien de but Jordan dousin prend la
parole c'est des joueurs comme nous et
encore ça se trouve ils sont même que
nous on va leur rentrer dedans on va y
arriver vous inquiétez pas mi-temps
prend pas de butin on revient 0-0
minimum les joueurs d'Olivier jeanvr
réalisent une bonne entame de match
poussé par des supporters chauffés à
blanc le staff saquantinois avait choisi
de jouer avec un bloc défensif très bas
pourer la vitesse de course des
attaquants au sererrois malgré ce rideau
défensif les ivelinois pris par l'enjeu
encaissent un premier but sur corner sur
cette déviation au premier
poteau dans ce premier acte malgré la
possession B les roues et noir ne
collectionnent pas les occasions de but
excepté sur coup de pied arrêé et les
Bourguignons creusent l'écart juste
avant la mi-temps sur cette superbe
ouverture direction les vestiaires
pendant ce tempsl les supporters
commencent à être
fatalistes
niau
maison pour le moment ilont ce qu'il
peuvent les petitun en seconde période
les joueurs d'Olivier Jan ne lâchent
rien mais la supériorité auise se fait
sentir au fil des minutes sur cette
ouverture côté droit Jordan dousin
attrape la jambe de l'attaquant au
Serrois le penalty est transformé le
sort du match cé dans les dernières
minutes Jordan dousin encaissera un 4e
but plutôt anecdotique le rêve passe les
ocerrois été trop fort et se sont
logiquement imposés mais la fierté du
parcours effectué domine malgré la
défaite je pense qu'on n pas développé
le foot que on développe de d'habitude
maintenant bon ben on tombe quand même
contre un centre de formation c'est les
joueurs qui qui ont du football qui ont
du ballon bon on a pas à rougir 4-0 bon
voilà quoi on perd mais on a vraiment
pas à rougir dans notre performance et
en tout cas je félicite vraiment mes
joueurs parce que ils nous ont fait un
parcours exceptionnel on peut le dire et
donc voilà je suis vraiment fier fier
pour eux fier pour le club ça a été
difficile on a vu l'écart qu'il y avait
mais bon on s'est battu jusqu'à la fin
et puis on a on a pas de on n pas avoir
de regret on n pas on peut on peut lever
la tête parce on a fait un bon match
quoi se Grégory Chassin et ses copains
vont devoir oublier cette élimination et
se replonger très vite dans leur
quotidien le championnat de première
division de district la couverture non
ça n'arrive pas nous a rejoint sur ce
plateau Guy Galanti le le directeur
technique du club bonsoir à vous pour
débriefer ce match un petit peu plus
amplement Olivier on en parlait tout à
l'heure sur ce match qu'est-ce qui vous
a manqué concrètement en terme de
jeu qu'est-ce qui nous a manqué
peut-être on a eu peut-être un peu peur
à l'entamme du match on éétait pas assez
libéré je pense et oui je pense qu'on a
y a certains joueurs qui ont été pris
par l'enjeu et qui étaient peut-être pas
leur niveau donc ça aussi peut-être que
ça a peut-être un peu jouer sur la
physionomie du match malgré des des
supporters qui étaient gonfl à bloc he
là on peut dire que les supporters du CL
ils ont joué le rôle de 12e h 12e homme
là on peut le dire franchement c'était
c'était vraiment exceptionnel pour les
joueurs et pour pour le club parce que
vraiment ça a été quelque chose de très
très très fort on peut dire alors je
crois que comme le disait Olivier on bon
tout on va pas remercier quelqu'un de
particulier dans dans le groupe mais ce
groupe de supporter ont travaillé
pratiquement une semaine donc on les
remercie et je crois que c'est la
naissance d'un groupe de supporters pour
le club ah ça a
déclenchétion et puis ça ça a déclenché
bon il y avait beaucoup de monde plus de
500 personnes je crois qu' on assisté au
match un parcours exceptionnel des
joueurs exceptionnels parce que on est
arrivé à un résultat quand même qui est
exceptionnel pour le club ouais 64e de
de finale je le répète quand même une
première historique pour pour le SG mais
bon il y a un essort cétait une pression
peut-être aussi pour les joueurs de
jouer devant 500 personnes par exemple
en tribune ça arrive pas tous les jours
non çave et ça change quelque chose dans
la on parlait du 12e homme justement
vous l'avez senti sur le TER
personnellement moi ça ça allait mais
j'ai senti que chez certains ouais il y
en a qui avaient vraiment la pression
étaient pas comme d'habitude cétait une
première ce sera mie la prochaine fois
parce que l'an prochain j'imagine que
c'est l'objectif faire au moins aussi
bien que cette année oui oui on garde
une par voil voilà on garde une partie
du groupe donc il y a de bonnes chances
pour qu'on fasse un bon parcours
pourquoi pas enfin il faut toucher du
bois et de cette épopée le le groupe des
des U19 là parce que la saison continue
he il faut faut quand même y penser au
championnat le groupe en sort renforcé
par cette expérience oui je pense qu'il
va enessortir renforcé et puis de toute
façon l'objectif de début de saison
c'était quand même la montée en
Excellence donc je crois que là ils sont
ils ont pris conscience que il y avait
un grand écart avec oxer mais qui peu
faire le l'objectif de la de la de la
saison qui est la montée en Excellence
eten je suis sûr qu'on va y arriver quoi
sans problème on est bien d'accord cap
capit on compte sur toi l'engagement est
pris sur ce plateau on vous retrouvera à
la fin de la saison même d'ici là bien
sûr mais d'ici la fin de la saison pour
voir si vous avez réussi à tenir vos
engagements du côté du championnat vous
vous vous en disz un mot vous êtes en
tête he de de la de votre poule de
première division de district un un
bilan quasi parfait 23 points en cette
journée le deuxè mil sa est à 19 points
à égalité avec un voisin le plaisir un
nul une défaite la défaite lors de la
première journée de championnat j'ai
envie de dire que la montée vous tend
les bras cette année oui donc voilà
maintenant on va se remobiliser ce
weekend on est exemp malheureusement
mais voilà on va dès dans 15 jour on va
on va se remettre on va remettre le blot
de chauffe comme on dit et ça va pas
être trop dur de se remobiliser non je
pense pas non non non parce que bon il
hier soir il y avait de la déception
mais je pense qu'ils sont voilà c'est
des joueurs de foot qui ont envie je
vous dis l'objectif de premier de début
de saison c'était la montée en
Excellence donc on va se remettre au
travail et on va y arriver cette année
merci à tous les trois donc d'être venu
sur ce plateau après ce cette défaite
c'est verre mais logique en tout cas
face à auxer et puis cette première pour
le club 64e de finale coupe gambardé là
oui merci à tous les trois sans
transition boxe Wilfried ce weekend et
encour va va accueillir deux combats
pour la la ceinture de champion de
France adilam M MAD dit remet sa
ceinture en jeu chez les super moyens et
le jeune Marvin petit l'extraordinaire
Marvin petit part à l'assaut du titre
chez les légers j'ai pu suivre leur
préparation il y a quelques
jours Marvin petit découvre la boxe à
l'âge de 9 ans poussé sur le ring par
son père car trop bagareur et commence
alors l'histoire d'amour avec les gants
après je me suis je me suis inscrit j'ai
resté dedans j'ai aimé ça et depuis là
bah ça été ma pati j'ai je peux plus
lâcher quoi c'est en fait c'est une
drogue à seulement 21 ans petit est un
phénomène à chacun de ces combats
lesélan courtois soulève les foules le
protégé d'Antoine farouia a de la foudre
à la place des points il possède une
vitesse d'exécution hors norme et est
capable de terrasser ses adversaires en
quelques secondes je peux le toucher sur
un coup et qu'il se relè plus quoi mais
bon après je veux pas chercher le le
coup dur moi je vais chercher à boxer
j'ai je sais que j'ai 10 12 room dans le
ventre là je je suis bien prêt quoi je
me sens bien moralement niveau physique
je suis impeccable franchement je suis
prè amour au ring vainqueur du Tournoi
de France et de la Coupe de la Ligue
Marvin petiter a levé les bras sur tous
les ring où il est monté mais lors de ce
combat pour la ceinture de champion de
France il devra se méfier de
l'expérimenter Joël durant a bientôt 34
ans l'actuelle champion de France des
légers a remporté 17 de ses 20 combats
chez les super moyens Adila mohouadi
remet en jeu son titre national
l'occasion d'oublier le chapitre anglais
en octobre dernier le boxeur d'origine
comorienne avait perdu au point face au
champion d'Europe James digal une
défaite dont il a su tirer les
enseignements conforté dans sa
progression on suis ressorti plus fort
parce que finalement j'ai vu que j'ai pu
tenir debout face à un
mondial donc je m'aperçois aussi que mon
niveau augmente donc ça ça ça rebooste
forcément le boxeur élan cortois va
retrouver une vieille connaissance le
cogneur thaïtien Cédric bet dernier
vainqueur de la Coupe de la Ligue mais
surtout un adversaire qu'il l' a déjà
battu en 2010 le 19 janvier le team
farouia sera donc aux affaires et ces
deux boxeurs conuront vers un même
destin la ceinture
tricolore football box et à présent Bike
and Run Bike and Run une course une
course un peu originale Wilfried et pour
en parler ce soir avec nous sur le
plateau Vincent Guyon vous êtes le
président de Versailles triathlon et
vous participez à l'organisation du
biking run qui se déroule ce dimanche
dans le domaine de Versailles tout à
fait bonjour Alors expliquez-nous un
petit peu bah ce quel le principe parce
que Wilfried était un
peu al le Bike and Run c'est c'est une
épreuve très ludique qui se court à deux
c'est c'est en binôme donc il y a un un
VTTiste et un coureur à pied les deux
ont un casque de vélo et l'idée sur le
parcours c'est de changer que le courur
devienne vtétiste et ainsi de suite et
celui qui cour derrière va pas courir
pendant tout le
parcours forcément un desésavantages par
rapport à l'ARE ex exactement et et
l'intérêt c'est que normalement quand on
est sur le vélo on se repose pendant que
l'autre court c'est pas toujours vrai
dans certaines configurations surtout
sur des petits singles mais mais c'est
voilà c'est le c'est le principe et sur
le départ il y a que les coureurs qui
partent et ensuite ils vont rejoindre
leur binôme à 400 m un peu plus loin
donc les 400 prers m vont sont très très
rapides en général et alors il y a des
changements des passages de relais des
zones de passage de relais alors il y a
pas de zon de passage de relais ça se
fait à la main à la main et on fait
comme on veut donc l'idée les meilleurs
c'est on va dire ils vont ils vont
alterner toutes les minutes mais il y a
plein de stratégies et surtout suivant
les difficultés les stratégies évoluent
au fil de la course donc on se pass on
s'encourage on fait évoluer la stratégie
ce qui fait que ça rend lesépreuve
effectivement très ludique en fonction
des conditions météo aussi on a vu des
images de l'épreuve de l'année dernière
il y avait de la neige forcément ça doit
jouer aussi exactement ça joue ça glisse
ça demande un peu plus de technicité
c'est ça fait partie du jeu c'est ce qui
c'est ce qui rend attractif alors le le
backing run c'est un peu l'épreuve de
rentrée j'ai envie de dire pour pour les
triathlètes chevronnés exactement donc
l'idée c'est que là on est dans une
période hivernale donc les entraînements
c'est beaucoup de travail foncier là
c'est l'occasion de de pouvoir épingler
un dossard et de faire un petit peu de
rythme et ces fameuses séances de
multi-enchaîné qui sont cherses au
triathlètes euh alterner vélo course à
pied pour habituer ses euh B ces fibbres
musculaires à l'effort euh qui va
arriver bientôt sur le triathlon et
alors sur le le Bike and Run il y a
plusieurs parcours on peut c'est quand
même relativement abordable c'est tout à
fait abordable il y a t il y a tous les
niveaux ça va y avoir de un de très très
bon niveau euh des très bon niveau
national mais aussi tout le monde peut
venir c'est c'est ouvert à tous et ça va
du mini poussin jusqu'au vétéran donc
mini poussin c'est 7 ans jusqu'aux
vétéran évidemment avec des distances
adaptées pour les mini poussin poussin
et pupill et aussi andisport je tiens à
préciser parce qu'on a toujours cette
composante c'est un parcours de 2,m 2
sur le domaine du château de Versailles
autour de la pièce d'eau des Suisses
après il y a une course Benjamin minim
4,m5 avec une belle monté et puis enfin
pour les CAD CAD
junior euh et ensuite Seigneur vétéran
euh il c'est donc un deux boucles euh
deux boucles pour un total de 12 km 8
sauf pour les mini euh pardon pour les
cadets et juniors qui eux ne feront
qu'une seule boucle euh voilà donc sur
le domaine du château de Versailles avec
en empruntant les bois de l'ONF et euh
d'ailleurs je me permets de remercier
l'ONF le domaine de Versailles et aussi
la ville de Versailles qui sans eux et
sans notre équipe de bénévoles très
efficace et et danse nous permet de
proposer cette épreuve dans un joli
cadre en plus exactement avec toute
l'histoire du patrimoine et juste
d'ailleurs sur le parcours un moment on
a un point de vue qui domine le château
de Versailles qui est assez magnifique
rien pour ça il faut le faire exactement
même si c'est difficile et alors vous
avez aussi une nouveauté cette année je
crois il y a il y a un challenge
entreprise université qui qui exactement
cette année on essaie de mettre en place
un challenge université et enfin donc
université grandes écoles et entreprises
où il y aura un podium dédié pour pour
pour cette catégorie c'est ça fait
partie de la cohésion de groupe souvent
c'est c'est recherché en plus le back
and run se prête parfaitement à ce style
de de philosophie et alors en terme de
de participants vous en êtes à combien
et est-ce qu'on peut encore s'inscrire
on peut on peut encore s'inscrir
certainement moi non voilà comme chaque
semaine je le rappelle moi non s'il
n'ige pas Wilfrid c'est jouable à de je
cours et vous faites le vélo pour ce
serait bien ce serait bien donc oui on
peut on peut s'inscrire encore sur le
site internet jusqu'à jeudi soir et il
n'y aura pas d'inscription sur place
donc ça c'est important de de le noter
l'an dernier on a eu 800
participants cette année on va on est
autour de 600 à peu près pour le moment
mais il y a encore de la place donc il y
a pas de problème n'hésitez pas voilà et
on reviendra bien sûr sur cette
compétition la semaine prochaine merci
merci beau d'être venu nous parler du
Bike and Run Anthony l'essentiel du
weekend dans ce 78 sport sur TV fil on
part pour l'instant à voisin de
Bretonneux oui nous allons nous rendre
sur le pas de tir de l'association
vinoise ce weekend le club de voisin le
breteneux accueiller une manche du
championnat régional de tir à la
carabine et au pistolet l'occasion de de
mieux comprendre cette discipline imag
de Guillaum
CS près de 200 tireurs s'affrontaient ce
weekend au club de tir de voisin le
breteneux lors de la manche de
championnat régional de tir carabine et
pistolet à 10 m lors de ces concours le
calme est le maître mot chaque geste est
millimétré de la mise en place des pieds
sur le sol à la pose de la carabine sur
les épaules tout est fait avec calme et
précision pour ne pas être perturb l du
tir expliquez-nous les qualités pour
être un bon tire
assidu
attentif qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait dire
encore pas avoir de stress calme posé et
maîtrce de soi surtout Pauline Laurent
découvre le tir en suivant son père près
des cibles la carabine devient vite sa
spécialité à 14 ans elle ne s'entraîne
désormais qu'une seule fois par mois
pourtant elle fait partie des 30
meilleures tireuses françaises de sa
catégorie çaésente quand même beaucoup
coup parce que je suis en compétition
donc c'est une grande partie pour moi
parceen plus on met beaucoup sur mes
épaule donc ma famille les gens du club
donc c'est beaucoup lors du concours
5entinois la versaillaise a porté son
score à environ 360 points sur 400
Pauline Laurent fait partie des 9
tireurs Vinois qualifiés pour les
championnats de France du 5 au 9 février
prochain l'essentiel des résultats en
bref à présent ce weekend on débute par
du hand féminin Montini le bretonne qui
je les les féminines recevaient le Le
Havre ce weekend actuel 2e du
championnat de National 2 malgré une
belle résistance en première période
avec un but de retard à la pause les
inimonaines ont cédé du terrain peu à
peu en seconde mi-temps et se sont
inclinés de peu 33 buts à 29 les
joueuses de Stéphane paysan rétrogradent
à la 9e place deux résultats de basket
tout d'abord du côté de trappe et
l'Étoile sportive des cheminau de trappe
qui semble avoir renoncé cette saison
oui ça ça devient de plus en plus
compliqué hein pour les les basketteurs
trapistes championnat de France de
National de masculin ils se sont
inclinés à domicile face à tourcoin 65 à
54 l'avenir en National 2 devient de
plus en plus sombre et de leur côté les
les féminines de l'Entente le chîn et
Versailles bah enchaîne avec une 13e
victoire cette saison les joueus de
vinco Bardic se sont imposés sur leur
parquet face à l'avant-dernier Saran 74
à 56 du volet également pour le club
cinquentinois c'est le weekend pour les
pour les clubs cinquentinois lors de la
11e journée de de Régionale 1 Montini
s'est incliné de justesses à Conflant 37
à 2 avec une 5e manche au couteau perdu
15 à 10 et le leader plaisir a chuté à
domicile 37 à1 face à camou au
classement on va voir d'ailleurs le
classement tout de suite plaisir reste
leader malgré ce fau pas avec 26 points
mais le pakamou revient à un point pour
montinis c'est toujours le ventre mou du
championnat les inis monte un point
désormais à la 6e place de la poule B de
régionalun le vent des globes n'est pas
terminé mais pour autant on s'y
intéresse pour voir ce que fait comment
ça se déroule pour le régional de
l'étape pourou gu de la mot après 65
jours de course c'est toujours François
gabar qui mène la flotte largement en
tête le leader aura passé d'ailleurs
l'équateur d'ici d'ici demain notre
marin versaillais Tangui de la Motte est
toujours installé à la 11e place du
classement général à 3700000 c'est c'est
c'est beaucoup hein c'est presque 7000
km de François gabar mais surtout à
140000 de de Bertrand de Broc le 10e du
classement général donc rien n'est fait
pour cette place le skippper
d'initiative cœur devrait franchir le
caporne dans quelques heures le tirage
des 32e de finale c'est du football du
football féminin euh le tirage a été
effectué cette semaine pour les 32e de
finale de la Coupe de France et la es
Montini qui est entré tranquillement il
y a quelques semaines en LCE au tour
précédent a hérité d'un poids lourd du
de Division 1 pour ce tour puisque les
inontaines vont recevoir ni plus ni
moins que les féminines du PSG et puis
une toute dernière information de la
boxe on en a parlé brièvement tout à
l'heure mais il y a aussi une
compétition il y a une compétition et un
club qui vient qui vient de s'ouvrir
c'est du côté de de Fontenel Fleury
l'école de boxe s'est ouverte en
septembre donc aviomes amateur vous
pouvez retrouver tous les renseignements
sur internet le 78 sport est terminé
c'était déjà le 2è numéro oui deè numéro
du 7 SP ça passe vite on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine ouif le 78 sport
touche à sa fin n'hésitez pas à
commenter l'émission sur Twitter et nous
donner tous les résultats de vos clubs à
lundi prochain bonne soirée